you may be wondering what the child in
this video did to deserve this young boy
I don't know that's aggressiveness but
14 year old Deshawn was simply walking
home from school please here explained
to a member of public that he was
stopped searched and pinned to the
ground because he matched the
description of a knife-wielding robber
DeSean was in his school uniform and the
only description that matched was the
color of desean's skin
they just snatched his mobile phone from
him they then proceeded to push him
against the railings and handcuff him
the way the incident was conducted is
now under investigation but Deshawn's
mum says it won't change the lasting
impact it's had on her son
Deshawn's education has been massively
affected by this um we've had to
organize transport to get him back and
forth from school he no longer goes out
with his friends anymore
um and of course there's a big distrust
the Met police say that stop and search
is a crucial tool in helping to reduce
crime but that it doesn't underestimate
the impact it can have on young people
recognizing the importance of using the
tool with dignity and respect
but that's not enough for Janet she's
petitioning for a change in law which
would see the police adopt a
child-centered approach to these
scenarios
the bill would support stop and search
as long as it's done the right way
Jaden is sympathetic to police he
understands that they have a job to do
but at just 15 years old he's been
stopped three times already to be honest
the situation I did have was a bit
humiliating because at the same time
there's people coming out of school
parents around kids adults and it was
just a bit embarrassing
a child's first encounter with police is
vitally important because it will shape
the way they view them for the rest of
their lives but a new report by
independent think tankers farm that when
it comes to black children the level of
trust in police is alarmingly low
73 percent of young people trusted the
police but only 36 percent of black
children trust the police
and whilst 87 percent of white children
would call the police if they believe
they're in danger only 56 percent of
black Caribbean children would call
police
how did you I put these findings to
deputy chief Constable Tyron Joyce he's
developing a plan of action to tackle
some of these issues
as a dad I feel a sense of Shame as a
police officer I feel a sense of Shame
because every member of the community
needs to feel protected the only thing
that I would say in this plan is there
is concrete activity to demonstrate that
we're being fair to demonstrate
proportionality to give that level of
reassurance but before building the
foundations of trust the police May
first have to confront and repair the
mistakes of the past Sherman Freeman
Powell Sky News